In this lecture
sequence, we introduced
quite a few new
concepts and went
through a fair
number of examples.
So for this reason,
it is useful now
to just take stock and summarize
the key ideas and concepts.
The starting point in a
Bayesian inference problem
is the following.
There's an unknown
parameter, Theta,
and we're given a
prior distribution
for that parameter.
We're also given a model
for the observations, X,
in terms of a
distribution that depends
on the unknown parameter, Theta.
The inference problem
is as follows.
We will be given the value
of the random variable X.
And then we want to find
the posterior distribution
of Theta, that is, given this
particular value of X, what
is the conditional
distribution of Theta?
In the case where
Theta is discrete,
this will be in terms of a PMF.
If Theta is continuous,
this would be a PDF.
We find the posterior
distribution
by using an appropriate
version of the Bayes rule.
And here we have four different
combinations or four choices,
depending on which variables
are discrete or continuous.
This is a complete solution
to the Bayesian inference
problem-- a posterior
distribution.
But if we want to come up with
a single guess of what Theta is,
then we use a
so-called estimator.
What an estimator does is that
it calculates a certain value
as a function of
the observed data.
So g describes the way that
the data are processed.
Because X is random,
the estimator
itself will be a
random variable.
But once we obtain a specific
value of our random variable
and we apply this
particular estimator,
then we get the realized
value of the estimator.
So we apply g now
to the lowercase x,
and this gives us an estimate,
which is actually a number.
We have seen two particular
ways of constructing
estimates or estimators.
One of them is the maximum a
posteriori probability rule
in which we choose an estimate
that maximizes the posterior
distribution.
So in the case where
Theta is discrete,
this finds the value
of theta, which
is the most likely one
given our observation.
And similarly, in
the continuous case,
it finds a value
of theta at which
the conditional PDF of
Theta would be largest.
Another estimator
is the one that we
call the LMS or least mean
squares estimator, which
calculates the
conditional expectation
of the unknown parameter,
given the observations
that we have obtained.
Finally, we may be
interested in evaluating
the performance of
a given estimator.
For hypotheses-testing
problems we're
interested in the
probability of error.
And we have the conditional
Given the data that
I have just observed
and given that I'm using
a specific estimator,
what is the probability
that I make a mistake?
And then there's the overall
evaluation of the estimator--
how well does it
do on the average
before I know what
X is going to be?
And this is just the
probability that I
will be making an
incorrect decision.
For estimation problems,
on the other hand,
we're interested in the
distance between our estimates
from the true value of Theta.
And this leads us to the
following conditional mean
squared error, given
that we have already
obtained an observation.
And we come up
with an estimator.
In particular, the value of
the estimator at this time
would be completely determined
by the data that we obtained.
But Theta, the unknown
parameter remains random.
And there's going to be
a certain squared error.
We find the
conditional expectation
of this squared error in this
particular situation, where
we have obtained a specific
value of the random variable,
capital X. On the
other hand, if we're
looking at the estimator
more generally,
how well it does on
the average, then
we look at the unconditional
mean squared error,
and this gives us an overall
performance evaluation.
How do we calculate these
performance measures?
Here, we live in a
conditional universe.
And in a Bayesian estimation
problem at some point
we do calculate the posterior
distribution of Theta,
given the measurements.
So these calculations
involved here
consist of just an
integration or summation
using the conditional
distribution.
For example, here we would
integrate this quantity
using the conditional
density of Theta,
given the particular value
that we have obtained.
If we want to now calculate
the unconditional performance,
then we would have to
use the total probability
or expectation theorem.
And in that case, we can average
over all the possible values
of X to find the overall error.
So all of the calculations
involve tools and equations
that we have seen and that
we have used in the past,
so it is just a matter
of connecting those tools
with the specific new concepts
that we have introduced here.